[Applaudissements]
étudier la musique à saint bénigne ce
n'est pas qu'une affaire de grands
l'initiation commence à l'école dès la
maternelle
ils sont dans ces pays en ce1 ce sont
les pépinières de voix ils ont travaillé
avec une maîtresse en maternelle et à
partir du cp chili prend deux fois une
demi heure par semaine et je les prends
en cm1 aussi deux fois une demi heure
par semaine donc on travaille le corps
on travaille les cordes vocales
on travaille le souffle la tenue et au
monde trois spectacles par an à partir
du ce2 et jusqu'en cm2 c'est la pré
maîtrise dans des classes à horaires
aménagés avec un programme déjà plus
ambitieux ces deux schémas travaille sur
un opéra qui s'appelle à quad look et le
grand donc c'est l'histoire du dernier
grand pingouin et c'est surtout une
question qu'est ce qu'on va faire de la
terre et est ce qu'on va exterminer tous
les animaux et qu'est ce qu'on pourrait
faire pour aider notre terre aller mieux
je sais pas vraiment comment le dire
mais j'aime bien venir ici avec edith
gens ce qui est du telma peut aider à
avoir mieux conscience en moi parce que
enfin avant j'avais un peu peur des
chantiers dont beaucoup de personnes
j'en faisais déjà comment j'étais en
petite section
mais c'était pas sérieux le faisait de
temps en temps je faisais de quelques
chansons et c'était vraiment c'est
devenu sérieux à partir de cp je crois
que je vais être guitariste en métier et
chantèrent en même temps
rendez vous dans quelques années à la
maîtrise de la 6e à la 3e
le chemin est tout tracé
[Musique]
le
mais en pleine adolescence la voie des
garçons se transforment ils deviennent
baryton ténor des voix fragile ceux là
sont regroupés dans un cours adapté ce
sont des garçons 4e et 3e sont que 4
cette année puisqu'ils sont en muet où
ils ont déjà miné donc ils font partie
du jeune du jeune choeur ne doivent pas
forcer sur leur voie surtout quand on
chante le vendredi soir avec les adultes
ils doivent surtout essayer de chanter
normalement mais sans vouloir faire
aussi fort que la voie du ltte qui
chante avec eux tous ces jeunes
s'inscrivent dans la grande famille des
maîtrisiens depuis sa création en 1895
par monseigneur moi ce n'est la maîtrise
a évolué avec joseph chanson labéjan le
capot jean françois samson l'abbé
rolland et alain jaubert on a tous
contribué à valoriser cette oeuvre
et de fait voilà modestement comme des
artisans
on a mis en oeuvre une pédagogie bien
adapté à l'évolution humaine et
spirituelle de l'enfant et voilà et
cette richesse fait que de génération en
génération et a toujours cette maîtrise
est toujours d'actualité
remonté le fil du temps dans les
archives 1 125 ans d'histoire alain
jaubert etienne meyer actuel chef de
choeur et le compositeur jean louis
gants ancien élève de la maîtrise
directeur honoraire du conservatoire de
dijon chef de choeur de l'ensemble
joseph samson y découvre des trésors
c'est là par contre est plus ancienne
elle songe à droite et c'est tout
mais moi ce n'est complet et moi ce
n'est là et des taties
une fois tout ça c'est votre
l'anthologie par contre oui c'est assez
mouvance de voir d'autres qui à un
moment donné commune aujourd'hui sont
dans l'action
concentré pour que ce soit beau c'est ça
c'est autant de autant de visages qui
sonde voilà que concentrer sur ses
résultats pour obtenir une chose qui
soit belle c'est très c'est très
émouvant c'est finalement sébastien
voilà un livre tout à fait
traditionnelle premier ouvrage de genève
chanson à william l'autographe de
nouveaux choix montre sans sommeil mais
à des puissances ennemies le voilà
[Musique]
et comme disait joseph samson on
n'arrête pas l'homme qui chantent
[Musique]